stephen's with us stephen is in columbus
ohio hi stephen
how are you hi dave how are you sir
better than i deserve that's for sure
how can i help
happy here had to hear that um i got a
question for you have a young
entrepreneur daughter we actually just
recently put in a
new commercial kitchen basically in our
house
she started up a bakery doing ice sugar
cookies and
it's just kind of taken off kind of
blowing up actually
um and i was curious what to do with um
kind of setting her up for the future
what what your recommendation is for a
10 year old to do with her money besides
so at the stages and count
[Music]
so how much has she made with her sugar
cookies
um it's kind of you know it goes month
to month depending on holidays you know
it started yeah
i mean just roughly i mean um i'm going
to say roughly
she's right at a month last month was
like
5.50 this month pushing the thousand
bucks
oh that's awesome wow that's great man
okay
well here's what i'm gonna do when i get
done i'm gonna put you on hold kelly's
gonna pick up i'm gonna send you a copy
of anthony o'neil's
teen entrepreneur toolbox which is a
toolbox that
helps parents work with their teenagers
on setting up and running a
small business appropriately here's the
main thing i want parents to remember
about money and about entrepreneurship
when you're 10 12 14 even 16 years old
the investing in some big investment
that's going to be worth 8 bazillion
dollars when you're 65 years old
is some fun math to run out and it's not
a bad teaching tool
but then but 99 of what your 10 year old
needs to take away from this experience
is the entrepreneurial skills and
confidence
it's not the money the money in the
scope of her life is irrelevant because
you have a young rock star on your hands
and so you know like when rachel was
growing up rachel cruz
you know sharon i kept looking at each
other going we have to point this one at
something because it's going to go off
you know and that's what you're doing
here right you you're got you know
your your children in the bible says are
arrow in your
quiver and so what you want is you want
them to fly
straight when you release the bow
and that's what this is all about it's
not about a thousand dollars a month
because it's not fifteen thousand
dollars a month it's a thousand dollars
okay and in the scope of this kid's life
she's going to make a hundred thousand
dollars a month if you keep teaching her
these skills
and so i think what you need to do is
make sure you lean in on the lessons
and then i always take money with adults
and children and i divide it into three
categories
we enjoy some called spending we
give some called generosity and we save
some and you always all of us including
10 year olds need to be building
those three muscles at all times
the problem is often with children we
only teach them one or two of the
muscles
and it's not it's not optional either
it's freaking mandatory
like brushing your teeth or taking your
test and getting a grade
and going to bed when i tell you to
because i'm an
old school papa dave so uh you know that
kind of stuff so this is you're going to
save
some and here's why i'm going to show
you why you're going to give some and
here's why
i'm going to show you why we're going to
talk about it and you're going to enjoy
some
because sometimes you have a kid that's
a little tightwad doesn't want to give
doesn't want to give or doesn't want to
enjoy
sometimes you have a little spender and
they want to spend it all but you and so
they got a natural bent but also help
them develop those other skills and
these entrepreneurial skills
and that's what i want to concentrate on
here
and so under the heading of savings if
you want to sit down and continue a
deeper education with the smartvestor
pro
you can open up a little mutual fund if
you want to and put some of the money in
there
that's okay but the the moral of the
story is is this
kid is the magic sauce not the money
right
and dave tell me what you think about
this
while he was talking i was thinking
about myself as a parent of a 10 year
old
and my 10 year old gets really
zoned in on something for sometimes
months at a time
and it takes a couple of months and then
suddenly i start reading about it i get
on board and then i think all right i'll
learn about dinosaurs and then
right when i start thinking about it
he's off to the next thing
it can be really easy for the parents as
you were talking about to lose the
importance of the lessons here
and suddenly it becomes about keeping
this business running
right and not forgetting hey she's 10.
yeah right yeah absolutely two months it
might be soccer that she's dispassioned
about shut it down
shut it down it's sugar cookies don't
make your 10 year old have an roi on a
professional kitchen you may not need to
see this is what happens that's why i
asked what real money was he said she's
making
a lot of money and that is a lot of
money for 10. but i've also
had the call here where you've got the
child star that's right
you know and they you know they made a
hundred thousand
did a commercial and made a hundred
thousand bucks right freaking diaper
commercial the three-year-old got 100
grand you know what
that's happened i've talked to those
people and if you're not careful then
the parents get all invested and you're
that's how their their childhood gets
stolen
because they become a product they
become a professional right and they
become
about their achievement and how much
money you're going to make and that's
why we all gripe about parents who
overdo sports or
gripe about parents who overdo pageants
right or gripe about parents that overdo
dot dot dot because they're trying to
live some kind of very vicarious crap
right through their kiddo and he's not
doing that there's no sign of that in
his call at all
none whatsoever but that's the warning
is encourage
nourish the positive things guide them
give them some boundaries some guard
rails
so that this can be a healthy thing a
not a toxic thing
um but you can hold it really loosely
yeah hold it loose yeah they don't need
to be up at two o'clock in the morning
making cookies you know i mean it's
don't send your ten-year-old assault
minds and he wasn't doing that
and most people don't but sometimes
people go well the kid needs to go where
the kid's gonna go
no no they're a kid they're ten you need
to you need to go no you're going to bed
you're going to bed it's a sugar cookie
shut the crap up go to bed you know i
mean this
is it you know and so you got to draw
the line there and and and
back it in because uh you know adults
because if you don't then you've got a
30 year old with an expanded version of
that
and that's then they end up in your on
your show
yes calling in going i'm crazy
so they've lost their ever-loving mind
and that that's not how they call with
your show but
i mean it's it was the actual diagnosis
sort of
well but yeah i mean it's so it's so
easy
to take what your kid's passionate about
and it becomes your passion and suddenly
you're driving them towards an outcome
instead of letting them be a kid yeah
and then you get you know you can name
all these stars that were stars too
young right
the teenaged or that didn't have parents
who had good boundaries well parents
were just
crazier than loon and then the kid just
made a blew up made a bunch of money and
as a country star a pop star or whatever
14 years old and then all you've got is
expanded dysfunction
right later on because they never had
the ability to emotionally relationally
develop
and and have good solid boundaries and
process now again he's not got any of
that there was no smell of that
he loves his daughter yeah you sound
like he's proud he's very proud of her
he should be she's a cool kid
that's a cool kid i mean that's neat but
the moral there is don't overthink it
yeah yeah and don't make it in put in a
savings account local but i mean you
don't have to when you when you look
down and you go
five i mean a ten-year-old thousand
dollars it's incredible you go
and it's easy to go i gotta be
responsible with this
you know it's like yeah the be
responsible with the gift
the kid has that's the most kid's heart
that's the most important thing